hello everyone we have an interesting
game a game of eight past bones
some say it's a game of nine past bones
but I think it's a game of eight past
points but maybe you can help me sort
this out
the original name on chess Gamescom is a
remembrance of pawns past but I prefer
eight passed pawns and it was played in
1991 it was played in Brussels between
Nigel short and Boris Gelfand it was a
match for games this is game number one
and okay it's a it's a pretty slow game
in the beginning you know the Berlin
defence and everything but it's a it's a
great end game played by both players
and there really is a beautiful key
moment in the position where natural
throws the entire game into the air but
get funded doesn't doesn't seize the day
but you'll see what I mean
so short has the white pieces and he
plays e4 e5 Knight to f3 knight c6 and
Bishop to b5 the Royal opus and we have
Knight to f6 the Berlin defence short
castles Knight captures on e4v for this
is a standard line nice to d6 Bishop
captures in c6 d captures in c6 and now
D captures on e5 Knight to f5 is played
here Queen captures King captures and we
have rook to d1 with chick okay
King to e8 and now Knight to c3 Bishop
to e6 h3 Bishop to b4 now Bishop to d2
not allowing blacks to mess up shorts
bone structure a5 Knight to e2 Bishop to
c5 now and Knight to f4 hoping to grab
this bishop on e6 but Bishop to d5 if I
guess one will give up his Bishop eridan
at least he wants it to come with C
capture son d5 under bling his seat
bones nice to e1 now Bishop to b6 and we
have g4 Knights to e7 Bishop the c3 now
both layers improving their positions
Bishop to e6 and now you can capture
this bishop on e6 but now if
if you capture and have characters then
rook f8 is coming you do have to worry
about this F do pawn it's nothing you
want to go for
so after Bishop e6 nice to h5 now
attacking the g7 pawn rook to GA
defending and ninth to d3 Knight to d5
attacking the bishop and c3 so Bishop to
D to c5 Knight d2 F for night to be for
now
c3 kicking away the night night back to
c6 rook to e1 a for now rook to e4 and
we have c4 an interesting idea was a
three but this allows b3 and then this
isn't something get son wanted to go for
so instead get front plate c4 now
preparing a three
so basically forcing shorts to push a
three himself we have worked to dat
attacking the bishop on d2 and Knight
captures on e6 before that F characters
and e6 and now Bishop to g5 would a
tempo on the rock on d8 rook to d7 rook
81 doubling up on the e-file Knight to
a5 and this Knight is threatening to
jump to be three this will be a pretty
nice square for this night but because
of this night to if I move a short gets
an interesting idea as the knight is
kind of out of the game he plays rook to
eat a rope to eat - we have rook to f8
King to g2 age six and here probably
because that night is kind of misplaced
on a5 a short decides to go for this
brave move and he plays Knight captures
on g7 with check so okay giving up the
piece for two pawns rook captures and
Bishop captures on age six now pinning
the rook rook moves and our Bishop
captures rook King captures Bishop and
now Geffen has two pieces for the rook
and this isn't something you enjoy often
in the endgame but he does have a past
Jeep one in the best h-bond so
should be okay for short h4s played
Bishop to c5 King to g3 improving the
position of the king
rook to d7 now h5 wrote to d3 would
check f3 defending and also Geffen has a
dark square bishop so having your pawns
on a light square isn't a bad idea
rook to d1 rook to f4 now with check
King to g8 rook to f6 going for the e6
pawn Knight to b3 captors on e6 9th to
c1 not rook to e4 attacking the c4 pawn
Knight to D 3 and we have King to h4 and
here gets on captures the b2 pawn he
wants to grab the a3 pawn and the c3
pawn to create some passed pawns of his
own and it might seem any like an
interesting idea to go for something
like the bishop to have to check if the
King moves the knight to c5 forking the
rooks but room g6 is perfectly fine this
gets you out of trouble King moves you
pick up the c4 pawn all is well for
white so after King h4 Geffen grabs the
pawn we have came to g5 the king is
marching forward rook to d8 now rook to
g6 with check King to h8 rook to f6
Bishop captures on a three rope to f7
prepare to grab the c7 pawn Knight to d1
offering an exchange of rooks rook
captures and you can't really decline it
since you're gonna lose the knight on d1
rook captures pawn captures and night -
III rope to d7 we have a nice - G - now
II 6 c3 and rook captures on c7 this is
a this is why I think it's a game of
eight fast bones instead of nine
passports
ok there are nine points on the board
here and all of these pawns are passed
pawns and this C pawn is a passed pawn
but I don't think the c7 point is a
passed pawn because it's blocked by his
own pawn so I think it's a game of eight
passed pawn
but okay rook captures and c7 and short
makes it a game of eight passed pawns
we have b5 rook kept a roof to c3 now
Bishop to e7 would check King to g6
Knights to a4 would check King to f7
with an attack on the bishop Knight to
d5 defending the bishop and also
attacking the rook on c3 rooked the c8
with check King to h7 rook to e8 now not
along those pawns to be pushed but okay
he can go to e3 as the bishop is
guarding it
we have f4 nice to b6 now attacking the
rook living leaving his bishop on e7
unguarded but okay this does come with a
tempo on the rook and this is the most
critical moment in the game short is
completely winning this game he has five
past pawns on the King side against two
passed pawns on the Queen side Gelfand
has and he still has a rook and pretty
much any move here wins the game for
short g5 wins the game
a seven wins the game rook a six wins
the game pretty much any any move you
can think of that's not really a
catastrophic move well we knew the game
but a short place a move that is just
that a catastrophe he plays rook to e8
and unfortunately I mean fortunately for
him get fun didn't realise this get off
and continue the game with Knight to c4
for some reason maybe due to time
trouble I don't really know but after
this rook to e8 move get fun had the
simplest possible move a - and I don't
don't see how he can miss such a move I
mean there is no way to stop the pawn
from queening the night is still
guarding a8 the rookie can defend it
from there so it's quite strange and
it's very easy for white to lose the
game here there is only one move that
stops black from winning this game and
it's I mean if a move like this was
played it was probably due to time
trouble
so if short was in time trouble as well
I'd it's questionable if he would find
such a move the
move that save the white in this
position is rope the g8 and now if you
play I mean there's nothing really else
you can play when you grab the Queen
rook g7 comes with check King h8 now
rook g6 to threaten checkmate on h6 King
has to go back
rook g7 but check King goes here it goes
here it goes here it goes here and it's
a threefold repetition so it's a it's
amazing that both the short engagement
missed this although there are there are
a couple of more examples I know where
both players miss a winning or saving
tactic so I have two rookie eight Knight
to c4 was played King captures on e7 b4
geffen is trying to push now g5 King g7
f5 and after F 5 Geffen resigned the
game as it doesn't matter what he does
here it's made in six whatever he does
white is simply getting his Queen faster
into the game because his pushes his
pawn Porsches come with check and there
is no point in continuing this game so
in this position Boris Gelfand
resigned the game and although although
I mean it is a great victory it was a
very nice game going for the Berlin
straight from the beginning exchanging
Queens going straight into the endgame a
very nice performance but that rook e8
move that's that's quite a quite a doozy
so I do hope I do hope you enjoyed this
game it's somewhat different than the
other games I show it's you know not
full of tactics and great surprises
although it does feature this rook to e8
move by short so I hope you enjoy that
piece of piece of information and
history so yeah that's the game I do
hope you enjoyed it I would like to
thank Bartolome cruzinha and mohamed
hasip collar Akram for contribution to
my channel thank a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you all
for watching and I will see you soon